اعترف اثنان من المدانين الروس السابقين الذين قالوا إنهم
خدموا كقادة
لمجموعة مرتزقة فاغنر
بقتل أطفال في أوكرانيا ثم
مقابلات فيديو مثلي مع ناشط في مجال حقوق الإنسان
نشرها على
موقع منظمته.
يدي بهذه
اليد بالأمر ، لقد قتلت الأطفال ،
فهمت
أنه أمر
تم إعطاؤنا أمرًا للتقدم
وقتل كل شيء في طريقنا وإنشاء
دفاعنا في المنطقة ، افعل كل ما
يتطلبه الأمر وذهبنا وقتلنا كل شخص
هناك من النساء  رجال أطفال كبار السن
ذكورًا وإناثًا وأطفالًا
أنا أحبك الآن ، هناك طفل صغير
ميت في
الخامسة أو السادسة من عمره ، وقد
أطلقت عليها
الرصاص وأن القائد السابق يلقي باللوم مباشرة على الأب القائد ، فأنت
تعطي أي تقدم قائلاً إنه أعطى
أوامر بإبادة الجميع  في
بلدتين شرقيتين عندما تمت مواجهته بشأن
تقدم الادعاءات ، قال إنه لم يشاهد
الفيديو ، لكنه أضاف أنه لم يقم أحد
مطلقًا بإطلاق النار على مدنيين أو أطفال
وهذا لم يكن التقييم في واشنطن
حيث كان كبار مسؤولي إنفاذ القانون من
الولايات المتحدة وأوكرانيا يعتزمون مناقشة
جرائم الحرب  الملاحقات القضائية نقوم
بتكثيف عملنا لتجميد
الأصول الخارجية لمجموعات فاغنر
لحرمان المجموعة من الموارد
لتمويل أنشطتها الإجرامية في
أوكرانيا وفي جميع أنحاء العالم
لأكثر من عام شاركت روسيا في
حرب غير عادلة ضد أوكرانيا ترتكب
فظائع على نطاق واسع من أي
الصراع المسلح منذ الحرب العالمية الثانية وعلى مدى
أكثر من عام ،
حارب الشعب الأوكراني بشجاعة
واقتناع لحماية بلدهم ، لقد
عملوا بعزم ثابت
لتسجيل الأعمال الوحشية التي ارتكبت
ضد الآلاف من الرجال والنساء والأطفال الأوكرانيين
ومحاسبة الجناة.  من تلك
الفظائع التي تخضع للمساءلة
بموجب القانون
خاطروا بها وضحوا
بأرواحهم في الدفاع عن بلدهم